it is the reason that people stick
around until the end of a wedding
reception let's be real no it's not the
chicken dance it's the cake and here to
discuss some of the current wedding cake
trends is alexis pasquale and kiko lewis
from rolling and dough bakery welcome
ladies hi thanks for having us you guys
are really magicians i was telling them
i've been to their bakery before what
you do is unbelievable let's talk about
wedding cake trends what are we seeing
this year you know the most popular
thing that's in right now is definitely
textures whether it's you know spatula
lines or giving like a rustic feel maybe
even like a naked cake where the cake is
exposed that's definitely what is
popular right now we're taking a look at
some of those lines and you're talking
about very intricate designs like
diagonals and you're straight across and
it's it's a clean look but still adding
some dimension to it right exactly
exactly yeah as far as the flowers go is
that something that you're seeing a lot
of still or no fresh florals is
definitely the best way to go but the
faux flowers have definitely been
popular it's more affordable for the
budget brides and it actually still
looks just as elegant as fresh flowers
it helps all our out of town brides too
that can't find their florist just quite
yet because they're you know planning
from so far away so they go get their
faux flowers and they send them to us it
looks just as good now that's very
traditional they're very very clean very
beautiful let's talk about some of the
non-traditional cakes these are really
cool can you tell us about these yeah so
the moody look is definitely in for the
fall season right now
with pops of color and ombre different
shades
and you know typically instead of doing
a traditional white cake the colors
actually add more pop to the room so
everything in the room might be very
white and classic but the cake is the
last pop that everybody notices it
becomes part of the decor yeah it is
that is really pretty now are we still
eating
or saving the top part of the cake to
celebrate the one year anniversary yes a
lot of times a lot of our couples still
uh save the top tier but but you might
want to consider just you know coming
over to the bakery again and we make you
refresh wise that's a good idea because
i did the one year thing and how is it
frozen
it wasn't great but it was still cake so
i ate it anyway um let's take a lesson
in piping because i see what you guys do
you make it look so easy so i want to
see if it really is as easy as you guys
make it look yeah i mean you know it's
tip it's basically a pivot so the more
pressure you put at the top of the bag
will give you the amount of icing you
want to put on the cupcake like friends
like pivot
so like just squeeze from the top show
me first okay okay let me show you first
so all the pressure is at the top of the
bag okay and then i just squeeze from
the top
and then just pivot and that'll be your
iced cupcake oh my gosh you've seen it
you made that house
you've got it okay we're gonna give this
a try pivot pivot
pivot
look at that there you go
you guys want to hire me now don't you
yeah you want to hire me um and then can
we add a little uh bling to the top
just a little bit definitely a popular
color is that what you're seeing right
now for the colors for sure for sure oh
my god if people want to order a cake
for rolling and dough how do they get in
touch with you guys
well there's multiple different ways
either you know through our email at
info
rolling
indobakerylv.com or
yeah our website or even on our social
media platforms of instagram and
facebook yeah um and i highly recommend
not just wedding cakes but they're
cinnamon rolls they're delicious so
thank you ladies for joining us i'm
going to send it over to you jillian